vivir bajo una constante amenaza de
muerte Ese es el panorama de unas 57.000
personas que según la agencia Nacional
de gestión de desastres de Colombia
Residen en las cercanías del volcán
nevado del Ruiz
Pero cuando explotó me escogió y ahora
no eso ya qué
tiene que ser ruido y caro usted se sabe
porque tiene semejante roto cuando caen
piedras allá rocas pues tiene que sonar
la zona de peligro del volcán Se
comprende en seis departamentos las
autoridades le hacen seguimiento al
menos unas 2500 familias que Residen en
esas áreas y se resisten abandonar su
vivienda incluso a pesar de haber vivido
su última gran explosión en el año
1985 en ese entonces una erupción mató a
más de 25.000 personas en lo que se
considera el mayor desastre natural con
registro en Colombia El Instituto
smisonian asevera que fue la cuarta
erupción volcánica que más muertes has
registrado en la historia de la
humanidad eso ya
erosionó lo que iba a erosionar
yo creo que rocas que caen allá y por
eso se pone así pero si acaso de pronto
para ir por los ríos hacia crezcan algo
pero que vuelva a ser erosión No creo
a mí me tocó verlo explotar y se nos
caía piedra encima cuando estábamos en
entre Valles el presidente colombiano
consciente del peligro ordenó acelerar
las labores de traslado de los
residentes de las zonas rojas le hemos
pedido a los consejos de riesgos
departamentales que aceleren la
evacuación preventiva de 2.500 familias
que están en alto riesgo por la
contingencia del nevado del Ruiz el
aumento de la actividad sísmica hizo que
el gobierno elevará la alerta a color
naranja el penúltimo nivel de riesgo
registrado